لقد انهيت للتو اجتماعا مثمرا اخر مع
زعماء الكونجرس بشان مسار العمل للتاكد من
ان الولايات المتحده لا تتخلف عن سداد
ديونها لاول مره فوفقا لوكاله للتصنيف
الائتماني فان اقتصادنا سيصبح في حاله
ركود وما يقرب من ثمانيه ملايين امريكي
سيفقدون وظائفهم في حال حصول ذلك لقد
اوضحت في اجتماع اليوم ان التخلف عن
السداد ليس خيارا ولا ينبغي ان تمنع
الخلافات السياسيه بين الاحزاب الكونجرس
من ايثاء الولايات المتحده بالتزاماتها
فلم يسبق لنا ان تخلفنا عن سداد ديوننا
ولن نفعل ذلك ابدا
[موسيقى]
توجه زعماء الكونجرس الى البيت الابيض
للتفاوض على رفع سقف الدين العام الامريكي
وبدا الحزب الديمقراطي مصرا على لوم
الجمهوريين في تعثر الطرفين في الوصول الى
الدفاع
المجموعه الوحيده في واشنطن التي تهدد
بالتخلف عن دفع الديون هي النواب
الجمهوريين اما الجمهوريون فوجهوا لومهم
الى الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن واتهموه
بالتغيب عن المحادثات لبعث يوم ما دفع
الامور الى شفير الهاويه
على الرئيس ان يقدم افكارا محدده ان لم
يكن مقترحنا في الكونغرس
تبدو هذه القضيه سياسيه بامتياز
فالجمهوريون يلومون الاداره الامريكيه على
رفضها التفاوض وخفض المصروفات نتسبب بتضخم
ديون الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي
تتخطى الان عتبه 31 تريليون دولار اما
الديمقراطيون فيلومون الجمهوريين بالتسبب
بازمه وربما انهيار دولار واسواق الاسهم
ومدخرات الامريكيين ومعاشاتهم وربما يكون
الامر صحيحا لو فشلت المفاوضات بين
الطرفين في اخر الشهر
اولا تخفض وكالات التصنيف ترتيب الولايات
المتحده ويتبع ذلك دفع الدوله فائده اعلى
على الديون وايضا بعض الناس لن يتسلموا
مدفوعاتهم في حينها وستكون هناك فوضى حول
افضليه وتوقيت الدفع
لكنه لا يتوقع ان تحصل كل هذه الامور دفعه
واحده بل يبقى الامريكيون على مسافه
اسبوعين من لحظه تقول فيها الخزانه
الامريكيه انها ستتوقف عن الدفع
وقد انتهى اجتماع البيت الابيض بالاتفاق
على متابعه المفاوضات
لدينا مهله 15 يوما لايجاد وسيله لخفض
الصرف ورفع مستوى الدين وتحسين الاقتصاد
وهكذا يبقى الاقتصاد الامريكي على شفير
الهاويه
وسيضطر الرئيس الامريكي لقطع جزء من رحلته
الى المحيط الهادئ للمفاوضات مع
الجمهوريين عندما يعود في الغنم العربيه
واشنطن